hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to little nightmares so
we just escaped from the kitchen which
means those shelves are gonna be very
mad at me and I don't know where I am
now got a machine in the background oh
is that the Sun good or zessica giant
spotlight okay oh no that's the Sun
maybe I don't want to jump to any
conclusions here because I still we
might need to be on a boat or underwater
and I almost went right into the drink
there okay how about you grab on to that
you know any day now there we go oh I
just love the scenery in this game it's
so expansive detailed like just the
water running down them why okay right
then oh we're shaking now Oh what is
that okay all right in we go
oh my eyes why we were on a boat we were
we was were oh my god
oh but why though maybe I could just
dump off into the ocean and be done with
all this but I suppose it's not the best
way to go by just all my god oh my god
why but why though why why am I got here
why am I do this
why oh wow legs but you know I guess
it's not too much of a surprise all
these big people need a big boat to
carry them all but I hate to ask the
question again but also why you know for
what purpose are they getting on this
boat is there like no land it seems to
be a lot of rain going on hi octagon
you're a big seagull again maybe I'm a
small person but okay goodbye I'll just
be going right back into the place that
I tried to escape from never coming back
okay gotta be careful here I can't go
drifting off the side whoa they're
wearing masks oh let's not look like any
normal human I've seen before they're a
bit too rotund then a bit bulbous a bit
oddly misshapen and waddling so either
they are humans or there's something
else entirely or they're humans have
that have been like morphed by some
agent some outside force that has
created this alter version of what
humans could be I don't know if that's
any better than the idea that they're
humans but no no kind of rather than
just be aliens and be done with it
although I expect in the long run I
don't expect my my questions to go
answered because something tells me oh
oh
you guys are gross hahaha I mean no
offense but uh they're just absolutely
disgusting everything about you is
repulsive to me oh my god oh you're
waddling such uniform fashion is anyone
gonna notice me but you just do oh hi oh
my god it's dead it's the a porcelain
doll lady from the very beginning of the
game I guess we're going into her
territory now don't notice me but I
don't know why you're not rotund like
the rest of them hi there
oh you're just watching aren't you okay
how to carry on in here sorry I've been
breaking your statues but obviously I
haven't been bringing a bowl Oh Mike I'm
so many questions oh no don't look up
here quick
oh my god they all have masks well maybe
not all of them I don't think that one
does that guy is just a chubby cheeked
jolly old whatever the hell you are oh
alright Snoopy all right Jimmy whoopee
okay we made it I think let me squeeze
quos into here and hopefully it gets a
little better oh I don't like the
shadows and I don't like the noises
that's why I must say as soon as I enter
this room here but you know I'm gonna
accept it all hello hello oh so this is
the result of those brothers hard work I
don't expect I expect I should just be
bothered by this hi hi we're enjoying
your band it's probably made of my
friends Oh
why they're just all gluttonous like
every one of them is so oh well okay I
was bothered by everything that I saw
and I didn't realize that I needed to be
a little more cautious there oh I should
be a little more a little more careful
about my things maybe maybe run this
done but grabber
you didn't see nothing - oh no oh no wow
oh god no no no no no I don't like that
war no no no no you got plenty of food
over there why would you need me huh oh
grandma you have looked better
oh boy hope no one knocks your stool out
from under you maybe that's what I'm
supposed to be doing here I guess he's
not changing me anymore so that's good I
think I got to climb up the stack of
plates but something tells me they're
going to be all all over me as soon as I
do oh no grandma no no grandma don't do
it grandma it's not worth it oh my god
grandma you're so floppy ha ha ha ha ha
oh my god
grandma you still after me are you have
you given up the chase ha boy oh good I
can dangle on this meat which is
something I've always wanted to do so
what's the benefit of this full swing
Swan oh oh that didn't do me dick dude
Lee can I post this know if you see it
off Ramone you oh my God look at your
droopy face ah look at her droopy face
no oh this is the most disgusting
episode yet no oh God Oh garbled out I'm
doing oh my god Oh [ __ ] drama
oh why am i standing here making you
guys stare at it longer I have no idea
ok so I got to get up there somehow
Oh I guess the stool just have to do
alright ok soon as I get up there I
gotta make a run for it some way Hobbit
a pesky hi come on come at me bro
Oh Oh fresh food fragile Oh get your
frickin gross sausage slurping Oh give
it up give it up yeah give it up oh you
guys don't try very hard
you guys don't try very hard to pretty
much anything so maybe it's not so much
that they're here for a pleasure cruise
they're here for a restaurant and
somehow they're getting all this food
and I don't know exactly how they're
getting all this food I have a bad idea
on how they're getting all this food but
and all these mechanisms that are just
bricked up for delivering more food
anyway
anyway though anyway okay you guys
having fun up there oh yeah you guys
have the good old try not beat your
hands while you're shoveling them in
your mouth
Oh gross gross Brooke come on I don't
know Aragon who do know you're the one
who love all you no no no it's not worth
it though but what Oh
nimbly bhimli I went over Wimbley been
bleep oh I've reached the desert area
good don't mind me
Smith smashing something tells me you
get and know what old Oh
okay all right then uh not worth it you
guys spend a lot of energy when you
don't need to ah okay oh no is you stuck
I'm gonna bounce across your rotund back
there Boyle and shadow key point oh that
was less of a point in more of a doink
uh okay got it nailed it though I'm a
champion here swifty into the winner's
circle okay all right we see if I can
skip it dude out here oh I see a
porcelain doll over there and I'm gonna
brag oh hi
I thought I got away from you I'll go in
the doorway
he'll never find it as a sink no where
did I go
it's the mystery truly definitely don't
check under here I guess it was uh fool
to me to think they wouldn't be here
because I seem to move
don't tell me he heard that ok I think
sick seasons all right so call me god
no wonder they have so many toilets god
these people are just frickin alright so
I gotta I gotta climb my way back up
there and figure out a whit way to get
to the door handle you can't go up there
alright I got dragged something over
maybe this jug jug some grabbable no
katomina grabs in toilet paper and hope
for the best maybe that's gonna give me
the boost I need if I said it is so
gently there hop hippity hop yep this is
a fruitless venture I don't know why I
thought this is going to work but okay
alright thank a climb up here ah
no I can't all right there's got to be a
way ah no but almost you be no but
almost okay maybe I could drag this know
this huh oh it wants me to throw
something in the mirror oh that's a bit
hard to understand uh that's a lot of
bad luck for me but okay I got get it I
get it I didn't know that this is a
pathway through here but okay I get it
alright so where to now do I have my own
private [ __ ] and closet or something I
just need to drag this over there or oh
I can climb up this thing okay I get it
okay I think I'm understanding this a
little bit better Oh long run a good
thing they built this just for someone
my size to be crepe ground all the way
through there alright here we go
I haven't little lantern in a while
don't know what the point of that was
our he's mishmash in his way downtown so
I just got a tiptoe along here not fall
like a goof that would kill me and then
grab that porcelain doll oh and then
smash it as hard as I can over there she
didn't hear a thing so I'm gonna steal
his ride and go in the elevator because
that's probably where I'm supposed to be
going and I don't know why I need to
release the black magical goop from
those porcelain dolls the evil demon
souls that are stuck within those
possessed beings
I don't know why it's necessary that I
do that but I suppose it's good question
are we hey hi nice mask
hey buddy can I give you a hug uh hug oh
well I guess that's important did you
stick his hand in a bucket of water said
that the heed this the bed that what you
did and also great practical joke but
also skirting with death a little bit
there and I suppose that's all I needed
to do okay then a little hug all right
there we go I guess we this way maybe I
can climb now where am I now what am i
walking into hey hey oh why why are you
all in a pile in there did you just come
out of an orgy oh my god I'm sorry I
disturbed all of you how did you know I
was here oh oh that's not comforting at
all oh that's the opposite of good oh my
god there is no need why am i this
delicious to you why freaks also didn't
eat me oh boy oh boy oh my god okay
that's that's normal I'm gonna assume
that
perfectly normal oh hey yeah okay yeah
yeah now oh my god your face no your
Slurpee mouth
oh my god it's Costas lady I got to
distract by anything Wow Oh Oh alrighty
then
oh I don't get it why are they so
obsessed with eating me I mean I get it
there are fables about Giants that want
to eat little children up but oh well I
don't get it
they've got enough food why do they need
more and what Oh No
I'm hungry now oh no maybe this is kind
of giving it a clue why I'm so hungry
all the time
ah me hungry me big hungry button didn't
mouth how does that put meat in mouth I
guess that's just the same as they're
doing but yeah boy this why I'm starving
so much is because I don't oh you gonna
be nice
gonna be nice oh you're nice let me
slurp on that slurp on that a little bit
oh you're so nice you're so nice I'll
take that yeah I'll take it any hope no
no
why can't you hug
why didn't do that
well I didn't do that is because I
didn't give up enough hogs why didn't
expect this episode to be in the middle
of a disgusting adventure and then be
emotionally devastated I get being angry
but this is too big killers get a munch
on this no I gave you good hug ah I feel
awful I feel awful I'm no better than
them maybe that's the difference maybe
they're just giving in to their hunger
and there's someone hello hi can you
give me some answers
hey wait wait II all right I guess grab
this and throw to the button oh I don't
know if that would have changed if I'd
given them more hard I didn't know I
needed to hug them all I would have
gladly given them hugs I'm gonna hide
because I have a funny feeling something
dark and demonic is gonna go there oh
the answer was and not quite but then
why would I be able to go up here yeah
alrighty then I'm gonna trust this I
guess not much left to trust in this
world especially not me considering I
just ate someone that was gonna give me
food I didn't choose that huh I feel bad
whoa okay you guys didn't say a goddamn
thing about having
Anakin's because if you guys are gonna
be having Brannigan's I'm gonna be
having a problem oh I don't like this
very much I don't like it at all
actually
oh that's all about but I think I think
it's bad so here's the bets I go in
there and it's a talking manikin number
one number two it's something even
scarier than all the other creatures
that want to eat me up outside or it's a
nice lady who's going to give me lots of
help and reward me for eating one of my
own I can do that too you know why were
you so ugly right
oh I didn't mean do well that was the
wrong solution oh no I did that well I
suppose we discovered what we're
supposed to be doing here is she's bad -
and she has magic which I suppose is
even worse
so um
[Music]
when she's singing
ah she's got a nice picture up there
I've heard the only place and all the
eyeballs okay I guess all right okay
who's the little girl on the wall I
don't know who's the person in the
yellow raincoat back there covered up by
the drape oh you guys seeing what I'm
seeing there
you guys seen what I'm seeing yeah
striking resemblance it is indeed so why
though but why though
okay so there's an answer or there's a
secret here so what am I do
I think I need to break this smoosh you
didn't hear nothing this is a bad hiding
spot homeboy you're gonna find me huh
maybe screaming wasn't the best option
okay
I guess maybe she's not gonna come kill
me which would be an amazing development
in this adventure but okay
I'm still going to take the sneaks
donkey route I'm gonna put on my
squeaking shoes or my sneakin shittin
squeak the Frick out of here so why are
all the paintings of this little girl in
a yellow dress covered up that is the
question
oh and she's gone
gray oh good the lady with a million
mannequins is mysteriously famished and
I am left to my own devices with a key
all right well I'm gonna still break
your dial
we'll be like that lady haha take some
of that and shove it up your butt
alrighty then sneaks nunk
sneaky torque please tell me you're not
in your own closet for some weird creepy
reason well that's disconcerting I'm
mildly perturbed by all of that okay so
it's weird right it looks like in that
painting up at the top where it was
obscured by the light the one in the
yellow dress that's kind of same as the
one at the bottom the face is all messed
up in that one you can vaguely see it
you can see it up by the clock up over
behind my face I guess but it seems like
the face is messed up so maybe my face
is also messed up much like everybody
else's face in this game it's kind of a
little bit wink wonky but I you know
maybe that's just you know the standards
of beauty in this here world that we
live in I thought that was her you never
know when one of these mannequins are
going to be her
let's just take this nice walking hell
oh no why is it cold in here is because
the spirits of the Damned are in this
place and they want to kill me dead is
that her oh that's not a mannequin right
there that's not a mannequin right there
that's not mannequin ended oh okay no oh
my god no no no oh I tried to run away
[Laughter]
it just didn't work I thought it was
going to work but I'm gonna run real
fast now this time I'm not gonna try
this negative baby okay yeah no don't
don't don't hit obstacles [ __ ] almost
made it there oh why did she did you
moan at me like that
god I keep looking at her and not where
I'm going so easy to get caught up on
the [ __ ] in the room here we go this
time running very fastly and not being a
goofy goober running into things it's
going straight for it don't report don't
groan at me all grudge style that's no
fun that no whole the black boopy boopy
darkness
I mean darkness okay no I'm defaulting
to a Crouch but I'm assuming that I
still need to run so I'm gonna go very
quickly cutting my bare feet on the
broken glass is probably something
that's not good for me see okay this is
the sort of thing that makes me question
your tastes here because I'm seeing a
whole lot of hellish horrors and not a
lot of good design here the Fung Shui in
this household is all kinds of orff
and also that big eye makes me think
that some other demonic entity is going
to be looking at me very soon so
what kind of magic power is that by the
way there is some sort of power some
telekinetic power going on that suggests
to me whoa I'm strong that they've got
something going on here and what is that
I don't know that is that an unbroken
mirror can I make her look at herself oh
I've got a weapon oh oh oh oh just like
link it's gonna blink blog the light
back I'm gonna make you look at yourself
and you're gonna explode with the horror
of your own face don't even think about
it oh oh you want to go oh you want to
go oh broke every mirror so that you
wouldn't have to look at your own
hideously beautiful miss we'll take a
gander at this lady take a gander oh oh
I thought this was going to be a lot
easier than that was and you disappeared
me I can you not do that could you not
do that
not a little bit bullsh in there okay so
there's some stratagem here I can't just
go running off into the darkness I got
to find her before she finds me and also
not cut my feet on the broken glass but
there's got to be a way that I can get
her to look at herself cuz this is
obviously my weapon this is my weapon
but if she grabs me then I'm a bit doom
and so she's going to go there so
what I owe
she got me from a long way away know
what I'm supposed to do what was I
supposed to do huh I don't know all
right then so there's a mystery to this
and it's not to do with the mirror in my
hand alone cuz I don't even think it's
to do with her maybe maybe I just got a
book it I'm trying to confront her but
maybe that's a bad idea and I should
just gun it I'm gonna come and go for it
i'ma go for it because that seems like a
good idea and I am not going anywhere am
I didn't the light
oh I'm gettin in the light I'm in the
light take that baby whoa
okay get back up get back up get to the
next light whoo that's the strategy
isn't it I got to reflect light into her
stupid face so that she can see her own
evil there we go there we go there we go
there we go there we go there we go yes
yes yes yes where are you are you back
ah ah take some of that baby oh you
don't like to see your own reflection oh
no piteous ugliness it's gonna get to
you someday okay
one more one more one more one more all
right here baby
right here baby oh we come from which
direction only one direction is gonna
lead to your death ah you can't be me oh
we're gonna be hunk o oh you know ah ah
gotcha that time okay alright rule of
three doesn't apply here but I still got
enough wherewithal to be able to smack
you into the next dimension really oh
right here oh good I was already here
you want to go huh what's that huh with
that Oh floating like a dino not quite
oh I hear that oh what's that oh no way
oh no way got you she can't take much
more than that
got to be like one more and then she's
dunes errs whoa
right back here apparently oh all right
that did good that didn't require a
whole lot of stuff come on I got you
little game of Simon Says ain't never
hurt nobody
Wow oh well that better have been good
timing Ronny and another weapon real
quick okay I'm gonna just take a happier
than because that seems like what I
should do Oh what are we go no oh oh no
not like this no not like this not like
this I didn't want to win like this not
like this what are you oh my god of a
little vampire Oh God
ah
[Music]
inclusion
okay
Oh Oh
maybe Oh No maybe it was Oh No
maybe it was my assumption my mistake to
assume that I was good in this endeavor
like seriously that could have been my
own I am NOT oh oh oh no oh no I have a
funny feeling you all are about to get
it you're all about to get it real bad
yeah oh oh oh sorry sorry to interrupt
your meal everybody know I wouldn't even
try that you know how to toggle warned
you guys not to try that oh yeah mistake
mistake mistake mistake
oopsy poopsy Oh
Oh
[Music]
all righty then oh wow hello will you
open for me now
well off I go then
with my new horrifying power of death
literally I just walk around and
everything is yes okay goodbye I guess
Wow Oh huh funny about that you know you
just think you're going to have a normal
adventure and then all the sudden you
end up murdering everybody on the ship
well fair is fair they were trying to
eat me so I guess I can't really
complain all that much oh hi hello we
come back oh I can't even come back okay
well I guess I can press on goodbye I
guess I am their God now looky Dookie
bin
and that is the end of little nightmares
not exactly what I was expecting
not at all but in a way very good I like
that a lot
it was it was a very linear obviously
and there was probably some other
aspects to collecting all of the the
things and hugging all the dudes I don't
know if there was a there would be a
different ending I have no idea there's
a lot open to interpretation here and I
kind of like that I kind of like the
open aspect of it the unknown aspect of
the absolute kind of open endedness of
it what does it mean was I good or was I
bad was I justified in my actions I only
assumed that I was good because I was
playing the protagonist but maybe my
ambitions were evil in the first place I
don't know it's hard to say I mean
honestly who does know but alas that is
what happens in LAN DS games when you
reach fandom so thank you everybody so
much for watching I hope you guys
enjoyed this one I know I did this was a
lot of fun and if there is another
ending you guys can find it for yourself
if you play the game and let me know
about it in the comments below I'm gonna
wait till the end of these credits here
and then see if there's anything there
and then I'll say my goodbyes so I'll
see you then
anything and the credits have been going
on so long that the music stopped and
these credits are unskipable by you i
even if you press escape even if you
press start on the gamepad nothing
happens I mean I get it I totally
respect it be proud of your product put
your name out there but at the same time
well boy that better be something at the
end of this because I am watching and
I'm looking and I'm looking at
everything
[Music]
hi I'd like to place an order for pickup
mark are you kidding me are you [ __ ]
kidding me I have food waiting for me
I've got stuff to eat and I gotta get
through this just to see if there's
something at the end of this I just want
to say goodbye Italy oh they're gonna
are they gonna go through every single
goddamn country I think that's gonna
every single country here every country
oh no I've got food waiting for me oh so
hungry I'm so hungry oh my god I was
close like always at the end of the
credits a little little day this is your
game oh five minutes maybe it's been 20
minutes it's been 20 nice oh my god and
it doesn't end oh my god it doesn't end
one of those the songs what is this what
are you doing game why are you not here
what the [ __ ] now
you just did the testers you just ended
testers oh my god oh my god are you
kidding
me game are you kidding me game are you
kidding me oh no I'm so hungry oh my god
I blame little nightmares for this
[ __ ] oh my what kind of [ __ ]
unskipable [ __ ] is this
I swear it's going slower than when it
started it's like he is like the speed
of the credits determinant on the
performance of the game like you because
I didn't get enough the little guys that
I'm going to go through there's a
hellish page like this is my punishment
oh I've got the hunger shakes I was so
hungry at the end of the at the
beginning of the credits I was like oh
man I can't wait to go eat I'm so hungry
I'm so hungry oh god I'm sorry
I'm sorry I ate a little guy I'm sorry
it's my punishment this is my punishment
for not playing it as good as I coulda I
didn't know you had dogyum oh god
someone saved me from this hell if
there's nothing at the end of these
credits I am going to go to little
nightmare headquarter and grab them by
the scruff of their neck and be like I'm
hungry fade me and then they're gonna
kick me out and call security
I am so couldn't have been as many there
couldn't there couldn't have been as
many people to work on this game
it is impossible is it looping is it
looping is it looping oh my god how did
so many individual people have titles
like this is it making a
if there's some algorithm in the game
that's randomly generating titles and
names how do there's so many individual
titles there's only one person per
category
you can't lump them together worker
group a worker group B in it what got
the double spaced everything what were
you trying to write an essay and Pat it
out so you met the page quite carry up
like what the hell I appreciate all you
guys were doing what you did my god
legal and business affairs Oh
Quality Assurance well there's no one
there for the credits that's for goddamn
sure wife AM wife am indeed wife and did
you put me through this I'm so hungry
oh I've got other things we need to
record I was gonna I was like oh at the
end of this game oh I'll go eat
something and then I'll keep recording
oh great did anybody test faster than
Arnold Esther testers did you have
customer support I need to call you
cuz I'm dying Jesus please save me Jesus
Barragan please undying I am so hungry
I know [ __ ] wait all the patients in the
Oprah I normally have all the patient's
in the world all the patients in the
world
I am totally okay with normally seeing
these club I'm really okay seeing it to
the end but oh my god
Oh someone save me I know I can't just
walk away I can walk away and probably
go get food and then I'll come back and
the ending credits will probably still
be going you know what I'm gonna
do that I'm gonna do that I'm gonna go
and get food if it happens if anything
happens you guys will see it and I'll
see it later and edit it in but I'm
starving I'm gonna go get food and if I
come back and is still going what the
[ __ ]
okay up I'll be back
you
oh well lookie-lookie loose so it wasn't
a loop oh I have no idea if this just
happened immediately after I left but
there you have it some sort of a
lighthouse which I can only or nothing
on a lighthouse that's like a smokestack
an island in the middle of the ocean you
can see the character by that doorway
with the eyeball so there's still a lot
of questions unanswered about this
universe but top-most is why did the
credits take so long I I I placed an
order for pickup it's not like I had
food waiting outside in my living room I
placed an order for pickup
I waited through the credits until it
was ready I walked I picked it up and I
came back before I got to this screen
like holy [ __ ] but either way that is
the end of little nightmares and that is
the end of this game for now I don't
know why they're on the ocean I don't
know what the I means I don't know why
this guy has magic powers I don't know
what would have happened if you would
have got more of those little guys but
that's a mystery for another day and for
you to solve so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought it's down in the comments below
and don't judge it by the credits but
either way hope you enjoyed it so thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye
Oh
[Music]